la toque est différente les habitudes
culinaires aussi qu'il écrirait few ce
travail chez sodexo à atlanta aux etats
unis elle est venue partager son savoir
faire avec les chefs français du groupe
nous allons passer les côtelettes à la
poêle en les saisissant et on aura une
belle caramélisation du port le groupe
sodexo a lancé ce programme global chef
il ya douze ans l'idée de profiter de sa
présence dans 80 pays pour faire voyager
les chefs et mélanger des saveurs quand
ils viennent ils viennent avec leur
envie leur esprit leur approche
culinaire leurs recettes que nous
restions au sein de nos restaurants de
façon à partager avec eux leur univers
est vraiment l'origine de leur pays
côtelettes de porc risotto de butternut
kelly que les filles sarah mené 20
recettes qu'elle va transmettre au chef
français
elle se nourrit également de la culture
culinaire de l'hexagone qu'elle visite
pour la première fois je dois travailler
que certains grands chefs français que
je n'avais jamais vu encore donc c'est
très excitant
j'apprends que le monde de la
restauration est énorme mais il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont similaires
avec ce qu'on fait nous donc c'est
génial
depuis trois ans que la filiale
française participent cinq autres chefs
de pays différents sont déjà venus mais
des chefs français partent aussi
apporter quiche lorraine et cassoulet
outre atlantique sébastien mme allard a
visité le nord des états unis ainsi
qu'une partie du canada montré à l'ado
pays notre culture notre façon de faire
nos recettes
et puis surtout de pouvoir voir leur
façon aussi de travailler parce que
c'est totalement différent qui
rigolaient fils va poursuivre son séjour
dans toute la france certaines de ces
recettes se retrouveront ensuite au menu
des restaurants du groupe